Trascrizione: Giulia Toffolon
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buongiorno, come state?
Solitamente, quando si viene a un TEDx
si viene per riflettere, per ascoltare.
io credo che soddisferò parzialmente
questa vostra aspettativa,
perché vi chiederò,
come farebbe un nuotatore,
una virata energica verso di voi
e che spostaste l'attenzione
proprio sulla vostra persona.
Qualcuno potrebbe dire:
“Ma cosa ci sta dicendo?
Lo facciamo di continuo! ”.
In realtà l'ascolto, quello autentico,
è qualcosa che non facciamo così spesso
e nemmeno automatico.
Se penso alla mia pratica clinica
come psicoterapeuta,
piuttosto che alla mia quotidianità,
io incontro un sacco di persone
che si lamentano del fatto
di non sentirsi ascoltate.
L'amica perché parla sempre lei,
il marito o il fidanzato perché -
voi lo avete capito cosa fanno,
gli uomini, mentre noi parliamo?
Resta un mistero!
Comunque, spendiamo,
anzi direi perdiamo, un sacco di tempo
a chiederci e ad aspettarci
qualcosa dagli altri,
piuttosto che pensare a quello che noi
possiamo fare per noi stessi.
E allora io vorrei fin da subito
cominciare a fare questa cosa con voi,
quindi faremo una sorta
di gioco, di esperimento.
Tra breve vi chiederò di alzarvi in piedi,
di mettervi a coppie
l'uno di fronte all'altro
e di appoggiare le mani
sulla persona che vi sta di fronte.
Come vi state sentendo all'idea?
Proviamo a percepire le eventuali tensioni
o cambiamenti corporei,
proviamo ad ascoltare
le emozioni che stiamo provando.
Magari qualcuno si è
un po’ agitato all'idea,
qualcuno è rimasto tranquillo,
qualcuno è sorpreso.
Adesso vi chiedo di fare
un passaggio ulteriore,
ancora più complicato in un certo senso.
Vi chiedo che cos'è
che vi è passato per la testa
nel momento in cui io vi ho detto
che avremmo fatto questa cosa.
Proviamo a recuperare quel cricetino
che si è messo in moto.
Forse per qualche donna
anche più criceti probabilmente, no?
Perché noi sappiamo che noi donne
abbiamo queste lavatrici
sempre in funzione.
Quindi proviamo a catturare quel criceto.
Allora, mi piacerebbe un sacco
riuscire a sentire ognuno di voi
per capire che cosa
vi è passato per la testa.
Per ovvi motivi non posso farlo
e quindi lavoro un po’ di immaginazione.
Allora, posso pensare che la persona
la quale si è sentita in ansia
avrà pensato: “Oddio c'è il Covid,
non si può fare e non ci si può toccare!”.
Quella che invece è rimasta sorpresa
avrà pensato: “Ah,
ma perché si può fare?”.
La persona che invece
è rimasta totalmente tranquilla
avrà detto: “Va bene, facciamo sta cosa!”
e la persona invece entusiasta
avrà detto: “Che bello,
finalmente ci si tocca!”.
Quindi, probabilmente,
a seconda di ciò che vi sta succedendo
e di ciò che state pensando,
agirete in maniera diversa:
magari qualcuno, con la scusa della pipì,
va in bagno,
qualcuno si distrae
cercando qualcosa nella borsa,
qualcuno magari fa la cosa
prima che io glielo dica.
Quindi si intrecciano queste cose.
Per farvele capire meglio,
vi racconto di una persona
che io conosco molto bene:
la sottoscritta.
Allora, io ho fatto per quasi 15 anni
nuoto ad alto livello:
sono stata pluricampionessa nazionale
di categoria nello stile libero
poi ho smesso,
probabilmente per un anno
non mi facevo nemmeno la doccia,
pur di non toccare l'acqua.
Dopo mi sono armata di coraggio,
mi sono riavvicinata alle piscine,
mi sono buttata nel mondo della pallanuoto
e a 23 anni ho avuto l'opportunità
di militare nella massima
categoria in Serie A.
Per questo motivo, proprio a quell'età
mi sono trasferita in Sicilia
e alle prime partite di Serie A,
ai miei esordi, un inferno!
Ma non perché le partite
fossero un inferno,
ero io a renderle tali!
E perché?
Perché i miei criceti,
sono donna quindi ne ho tanti,
continuavano a ricordarmi il fatto
che mi stavo letteralmente scontrando
con delle giocatrici olimpioniche.
La mia attenzione era
completamente focalizzata
sul fatto che non potevo farcela,
non ero in grado, erano più forti di me,
bla bla bla…
Come potevo sentirmi?
Ansia, agitazione, nervosismo:
i miei muscoli parlavano la stessa lingua!
E la prestazione
come poteva essere secondo voi?
Certamente al di sotto
delle mie possibilità,
quindi andavo a creare
un maledetto circolo vizioso.
Perché?
Perché poi non giocavo bene,
la prestazione era scadente
e questo andava a confermarmi
la mia convinzione di non essere in grado.
Sono dei circoli viziosi tremendi, eh!
Ma da dove nascono?
Forse stiamo cominciando a capirlo:
l'incipit è proprio quel criceto
che noi mettiamo in moto.
Ma mica è finita per voi,
adesso vi richiamo in gioco,
vi faccio immaginare un'altra situazione.
Devo raggiungere un posto che non conosco:
sono per strada, ho il mio TomTom,
ho il mio cellulare - non si sa mai.
Il TomTom smette di funzionare
e il cellulare - non c'è campo.
Panico!
Ecco quei criceti!
Allora, probabilmente la maggior parte
di voi, o qualcuno di voi,
piuttosto di fermarsi
e chiedere informazioni
preferisce puntare a un guard-rail.
Qualcun altro, i più coraggiosi,
dopo che sono passate almeno 23 persone
che avete scartato
per i motivi più disparati,
alla ventiquattresima vi fermate,
vi armate di coraggio,
tirate giù il finestrino
e già lì immaginate di arrivare poi a casa
e dire a vostro figlio:
“Figlio, ce l'ho fatta,
ho chiesto informazioni!”.
Quindi supereroi, no?
Finalmente anche il papà è un supereroe!
Ho tirato giù il finestrino,
chiedo informazioni - chissà in che modo -
e la risposta della persona
poi che cosa sarà?
“Non sono del posto”, è un classico.
Ma non dobbiamo scomodare
la legge di Murphy:
probabilmente abbiamo scelto
quella persona
perché in quel volto abbiamo riconosciuto
lo stesso sguardo perso e impaurito
che avevamo noi in quel momento.
Quindi come vedete tutto è nato
da ciò che io ho letto,
dall'interpretazione
che io ho fatto delle cose,
dal mio pensiero, dal mio criceto,
che mi avrà fatto sentire in un certo modo
e quindi poi agire in un modo
più o meno efficace
e socialmente accettabile.
Ma perché certi hanno dei criceti fighi
e altri invece hanno
dei criceti sfigati, zoppicanti?
Allora, la risposta è duplice
e quindi penso un po’
al mondo dello sport.
È un po’ come l'atleta,
che da una parte è frutto di un talento
e quindi di una predisposizione
verso una certa cosa - parte minima -
e dall'altra è frutto
di tutto ciò che impara
in acqua, in pista, sul campo,
da un punto di vista tattico,
tecnico, fisico e mentale.
Allo stesso modo, ognuno di noi
è frutto di una predisposizione,
quindi ciò che madre natura
ha scelto per noi, il DNA,
e la stragrande maggioranza
è frutto di tutti quei
condizionamenti ed apprendimenti
che noi riceviamo nel corso
della nostra vita,
soprattutto nei primi anni,
adolescenza compresa,
quando siamo delle spugne e assorbiamo,
assorbiamo, assorbiamo, prendiamo.
Quindi condizionamenti familiari,
sociali, sportivi, amicali -
qualsiasi contesto ci insegna,
ci trasmette qualcosa
e poi si trasforma nel nostro modo
di reagire alle cose,
di pensare alle cose.
C'è una bella notizia. Eh, ci deve essere!
Se noi siamo per la stragrande
maggioranza di cose
frutto dei nostri apprendimenti,
se ciò che abbiamo appreso
ci fa agire male, ci fa sentire male,
ci fa funzionare male,
non ci fa raggiungere i nostri obiettivi,
disimpariamo e impareremo
dei nuovi modi di funzionare
e di reagire di fronte agli eventi.
Questa è tanta roba,
è quello che ho imparato a fare anch'io.
E quindi ripenso a quella Daniela,
che alle prime partite di pallanuoto,
quando era una corda di violino,
probabilmente faceva percepire
questa cosa anche all'esterno.
Un giorno il mio allenatore,
che ancora porto nel mio cuore,
mi prese da parte, mi guardò e mi disse:
“Hanno due gambe e due braccia come te”.
A me questa cosa aprì un mondo:
apparentemente banale,
però mi diede l'avvio
per cominciare a vedere le cose
in maniera diversa.
E quindi cominciai a focalizzarmi
sui miei punti di forza:
la velocità, il mio essere spigolosa
e il fatto che ero che fossi mancina,
che è un valore aggiunto
in uno sport come questo.
Quindi quello, unito poi alle parole
della mia portiera canadese,
che un giorno prima di una partita,
probabilmente sentendo
il rumore dei criceti,
mi guardò e mi disse: “Stop thinking!".
Questo per me fu veramente l'avvio
di un nuovo modo di vedere e di vedermi.
Chiaramente, anche il mio stato
emotivo e fisico cambiò
e la prestazione cominciò a corrispondere
a quello che io potevo
veramente fare e dare.
Quindi dipende da me, dipende da noi.
Il tempo, il meteo lo subiamo,
ma come noi decidiamo
di pensare alle cose,
e di percepire le cose,
è sotto il nostro controllo.
Ci vuole allenamento mentale:
come un atleta allena la sua tecnica,
la sua tattica, il suo fisico
per diventare più veloce
o più preciso a seconda dello sport,
allo stesso modo ognuno di noi
può allenare la propria mente
per cominciare a sentirsi,
e quindi ad agire, in maniera diversa.
Allenamento mentale.
Dipende da noi.
Prima di salutarvi, vi vorrei lasciare
con un primo strumento di lavoro.
Un po’ come abbiamo fatto oggi,
quando ci capita di sentirci in ansia,
tesi, arrabbiati, frustrati, infastiditi,
fermiamoci e chiediamoci:
“Che cos'è che mi è
passato per la testa? ”.
Io credo che la maggior parte delle volte
la risposta riusciamo a recuperarla,
per quanto quel pensiero sia veloce.
Trovata la risposta,
facciamoci quest’ulteriore domanda:
“In fondo, cosa c'è
di così terribile in questo? ”.
La stragrande maggioranza delle volte,
io sono certa che anche qui
la risposta sarà: nulla.
Questo può essere l'inizio
del vostro cambiamento!
Allora, buon allenamento mentale!